en el vídeo pasado hablamos acerca de la
fórmula general para solucionar las
ecuaciones de segundo grado es decir las
ecuaciones de la forma
cuadrado v x + c igual a 0 y hablábamos
que esta ecuación de segundo grado
estaba en posición estándar porque
estaba igualada a cero además habíamos
dicho que la solución de estas
ecuaciones de segundo grado tenían la
siguiente expresión menos b más menos la
raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada menos 4
hacer y todo esto dividido entre 2
y además en el vídeo pasado nosotros
tomábamos valores para a b y c y
sustituye a mohsén esta fórmula que
tenemos aquí entonces encontrábamos dos
resultados porque recuerda que tomábamos
un primer resultado con la raíz cuadrada
positiva y tomábamos un segundo
resultado con la raíz cuadrada negativa
pero no te has preguntado de dónde sale
esta fórmula si tantas veces la vamos a
utilizar porque aparece esta fórmula así
de la nada será un dogma de fe y bueno
lo que quiero ver en este vídeo es cómo
se prueba o cómo demostramos qué
fórmula en verdad es la fórmula general
la solución general de las ecuaciones de
segundo grado y para probarla lo que
vamos a hacer es empezar con esta
ecuación de segundo grado a x cuadrada
más bx más e igual a cero y vamos a
completar el cuadrado perfecto así que
lo primero que voy a hacer es dividir
todo entre a no va a quedar x cuadrada +
b entre x más se entre a es igual a cero
entre am pero cero entre cero y estoy
dividiendo todo entre actual que el
coeficiente del x cuadrada sea 1 y sea
mucho más fácil factorizar bueno lo
segundo que voy a hacer es pasar del
otro lado el c / a o dicho de otra
manera lo que voy a hacer es restar de
ambos lados la ecuación se entregan
entonces me queda x cuadrada más b / a x
y aquí se entre a positivo y uno
negativo se cancelarían aquí no me queda
nada mientras que del otro lado de la
ecuación me queda menos c entre a lo
único que hice fue pasar el c entre a
positivo del otro lado con signo
contrario y bueno aquí viene el paso
importante de todo esto voy a completar
el binomio al cuadrado perfecto por lo
tanto lo que tengo que hacer es tomarme
la mitad
y quién es la mitad debe entrar pues es
lo mismo que un medio por 20 am que es
ve entre 2 am y bueno a estévez entre 12
lo voy a llevar al cuadrado aquí para
que yo pueda completar el binomio al
cuadrado perfecto y esto lo pueda
factorizar pero si estoy haciendo algo
del lado izquierdo de la ecuación
también lo tengo que hacer del lado
derecho de la ecuación no puedo
solamente poner de entre 2 al cuadrado
así de la nada por lo tanto también del
lado derecho tengo que poner más b entre
2 a al cuadrado más b entre 2 ha elevado
al cuadrado me estoy fijando en dos
veces el nuevo por el segundo o dicho de
otra manera estoy sacando la mitad
dv entre a la mitad de vendré a es b
entre 2 a over entre a entre 2 y bueno
esto se puede factorizar como x + b
entre 2 ha elevado al cuadrado y es que
esto es muy importante este de aquí es
un vídeo al cuadrado perfecto es más
para que lo veas más fácil vamos a
resolver este binomio al cuadrado
perfecto para que veas que es lo que me
va a quedar x + b entre 12 elevado al
cuadrado
es lo mismo que x + b entre 2 a por x +
b entre 2 am y que me queda de
multiplicar
2x x xx cuadrado x x b entre 2 pues es
de entre 2 x aquí tengo pues lo mismo de
entre 2 x y para finalizar tengo b entre
2 a x de entre 2 lo cual es de entre 2 a
elevado al cuadrado y si te das cuenta
esto es casi lo mismo que tenemos aquí
porque estos dos de aquí se pueden
simplificar y se simplifican en quien ve
entre 2 a x + b entre 2 a x pues es dos
veces de entre 2 a x pero el 2 con el 12
van en quedaría simple y sencillamente b
entre a por otra parte me quedaré que es
cuadrada más b entre a x + b entre dos
ha elevado al cuadrado y es justo lo que
tengo aquí te das cuenta esto me sirve
bastante porque entonces ya puedo
factorizar esta expresión que tengo aquí
como x + b entre 2 ha elevado al
cuadrado este era un trinomio al
cuadrado perfecto escondido y bueno del
otro lado de la ecuación que me va a
quedar me queda menos se entre a y
después tengo más b entre 2 ha elevado
al cuadrado de entre 2 a elevado al
cuadrado va a ser positivo por lo tanto
lo voy a poner primero y me queda pues b
al cuadrado entre 2 a elevado
lo cual es de cuadrada entre 4 a
cuadrada entonces déjame ponerlo estos
de cuadradas entre 4 a cuadrada y lo
pongo al principio porque es positivo ya
esto le voy a quitar menos se entre a
pero voy a escribir al menos entre a de
una forma bastante exitosa pero muy útil
para que podamos reducir términos
semejantes esto es lo mismo que si yo
multiplico menos se entre a por 4 a
entre 4 a me queda 4 hace entre 4 a
cuadrado lo único que estoy haciendo es
buscar un denominador común para la
expresión menos se entre a la para la
expresión de cuadrada entre 4 a cuadrada
fíjate como es lo mismo 4 con el 4 se va
nada con el cuadrado se van no quedaría
simple y sencillamente menos entre a es
este de aquí así que déjame unirnos con
una flecha para que sepas de dónde salió
este 4 de aquí y por otra parte de
cuadrado entre 4 a cuadrada es este de
aquí y bueno esto no está sirviendo
bastante porque ya puedo operar estas
dos fracciones que tengo aquí de
cuadrada entre 4 a cuadrada menos 4 hace
entre 4 a cuadrada a pues esto es
exactamente lo mismo
de cuadrada menos 4 hace entre 4 a
cuadrada 4 a cuadrada y date cuenta como
poco a poco ya se va apareciendo un poco
a esto que tenemos aquí arriba al menos
ya tenemos el be cuadrada menos 4 a 0 y
es que ya casi terminamos esta
demostración que estamos haciendo en la
demostración de la fórmula general de
segundo grado bueno a continuación lo
que voy a pasar es el cuadrado del otro
lado o sacando la raíz cuadrada a ambos
lados de la ecuación
entonces el cuadrado con la raíz
cuadrada se van y del otro lado que me
queda me queda la raíz cuadrada de todo
esto que tengo aquí y además recuerda
que cuando sacamos raíz cuadrada ponemos
más menos más menos pero la raíz
cuadrada recuerda que se puede dividir
se puede dividir entre la raíz cuadrada
de b cuadrada menos 4 hacen ya esto
dividirlo entre la raíz cuadrada de
cuatro a cuadrada pero la raíz cuadrada
de 4 al cuadrado es simple esencialmente
2 a la raíz de 4 es 2 y la raíz de la
cuadrada es a y ojo esto es muy
importante puso más menos porque
recuerda que cada vez que sacamos raíz
cuadrada nosotros tenemos dos soluciones
una solución
positiva y una solución negativa siempre
que saques raíz cuadrada vas a tener dos
soluciones una positiva y una negativa y
bueno esto ya está pareciendo cada vez
más a lo que queremos lo único que nos
hace falta es pasar el b entre dos a del
otro lado de la ecuación y ya con esto
vamos a obtener lo que queremos que por
cierto si lo tenemos del lado izquierdo
con signo positivo entonces nos va a
quedar que del lado derecho le voy a
poner signo negativo y me queda x es
igual a menos b entre dos a + menos la
raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada entre 4 ac
entre 2
y bueno aquí tenemos un denominador
común y entonces si nosotros hacemos las
operaciones de fracciones que me va a
quedar que x es igual a menos b más
menos la raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada
menos 4 ac y el denominador común es 2
am por lo tanto todo esto lo voy a
dividir entre 2
y qué creés acabamos de encontrar la
fórmula cuadrática o la solución de
estas ecuaciones de segundo grado empecé
con esta ecuación en su forma estándar y
después completa el binomio cuadrado
perfecto hasta llegar a la
la cuadrática espero que lo hayas
encontrado bastante y retenido como yo
lo encontré